ah here we go green day 27 yep this is
actually the guy I told this story a
couple of games ago when I accidentally
went 45 minute game and I was in bullet
mode and blundered the game away quickly
so I have played him once and lost this
the city silly game where I screwed up
the time control so let's see what I can
do in a in a real game wow that's
aggressive hmm yeah this this problem
Bishop doesn't have many squares IAM and
h4 looks like really looks really bad so
man ugly how did I come into this
problem Wow check okay not sure how bad
it is I mean it's not something that I'm
particularly thrilled about obviously
but maybe I have some some ideas so okay
okay that's it's not let's and free me
not that terrible if I get the night to
air for position is relatively closed
no this is this is quite okay okay this
is more than ok now here what is just
better let's see what I can do even Luke
be one comes into consideration but
let's just put the rook on p3 yeah its
leader getting absolutely nowhere this
kind of thing c 6-r look III hook a
three is also good here they are gay
three is good
someone can take them rooks III back is
also strong amp for takes and Roxy 6 and
Roxy one my King has completely save him
I think maybe he find something that I
don't don't see anything that vaguely
univ 8ly threatens my king yeah Bishop
up to c6 maybe or i can also let's open
up let's open this up rooks is six
rookie six i can just take with the rook
and queen c6
um yeah
I'm really
yeah okay I can do that so queen bee
hive I guess
check
that's it I hope black resins gym and
this was an opening screw up by me but
somehow somewhat it wasn't so bad at the
end yeah I also really don't get how you
can't play this in two seconds but ok
this is the internal story that hmm
considering that for example in a
situation where a black takes on g3 if
we just imagine this it might be an idea
to put the bishop on g6 yeah could be
interesting at least Jackie took them
immediately took their went back so yeah
maybe this isn't that much of a problem
with King f 2 i'm always securing those
pawns it looks ugly but maybe it isn't
that bad I ok this was stronger yeah
this is of course much stronger because
i don't have an even now as a square i
intended this move which is hmm yeah
maybe i'm trying for four play on the FR
you know once once i got to air for I
was pretty pretty happy jump IG I think
white has the attack don't really yeah
see 66 was even stronger here look see
one now this is all all winning with
with many moves and now this year and
you cannot hold the the King position
down mm-hm but I still wonder what was
my mistake there
probably probably ropes no book see one
I have to go that maybe I should somehow
just flick age three and or something to
let him take there or if he retreats I'm
having this square maybe this that's
really awkward to media h3 is so blah
and ugly move but I didn't really see
what else okay it was a win at the end
thanks for watching